Dois homens começaram a operar Bitcoin no
mesmo dia. Um passou 12 horas por dia
olhando para velas, perseguindo cada
pequeno pump verde. Ontem à noite, uma única
armadilha de baleias liquidou todas as economias dele. O
outro homem jantou com a família,
dormiu tranquilo e acordou com um
lucro de $5.000. A diferença não foi
sorte. Foi o sistema. Um era o
caçador, o outro era o defensor. A maioria dos
traders falha porque joga o
jogo das baleias. Compram quando dizem para
comprar, mas as baleias estão montando armadilhas
e você é a presa. O Trap Defence BTC
muda o jogo ao visualizar o
invisível. Nosso motor detecta
manipulação institucional antes de
atingir o seu P&L. Damos a você a habilidade
máxima do trading, a disciplina para se manter
seguro até que as probabilidades estejam ao seu favor.
É defesa de alta resolução para um mercado de
alto risco. E hoje você pode se equipar
sem nenhum custo. Junte-se à
Defenders Academy agora e receba a
edição mínima do Trap Score de
forma gratuita. Sem cartão, sem enrolação, apenas a
verdade crua do mercado. Pare de ser a
presa, torne-se o defensor. Clique abaixo
para iniciar o bot e garantir seu acesso
gratuito agora.